President Eisgruber, I have the honor to
present to you for the degree of Doctor
of Humane Letters honoris causa father
Gregory Boyle as a young priest in East
Los Angeles he found himself in a parish
wracked with gang violence and scarred
by poverty addiction and despair he
learned that while he could not dispel
this darkness on his own he could help
others to turn the light switch on by
creating alternatives to gangs in the
form of social enterprises grounded in
human solidarity and buttress by
rehabilitative services beginning with a
bakery in 1992 homeboy industries has
empowered thousands of one-time gang
members to read to redirect their lives
and like its founder is now a source of
inspiration throughout the country in
the world
Alto ratata Mejia Cora taurima's
hooniverse Satara spring catonian sis
camisa de agua Dom doctores in the
terrorists who money or a bus honora's
causa admitto